in the last video we saw that if a
function takes on a minimum a minimum or
maximum value min Max value for our
function at X equals a then a is a
critical point then x equals a is a
critical point but then we saw that the
other way around isn't necessarily true
X X X equal a being a critical point
does not necessarily mean that the
function takes on a minimum or maximum
value at that point so we're going to
try to do in this video is try to come
up with some criteria especially
involving the derivative of the function
around x equals a to figure out if it is
a cry if it is a minimum or a maximum
point so let's look at what we saw in
the last video we saw that this point
right over here is where the function
takes on a maximum value so this
critical point in particular was X
naught what made it a critical point was
that the derivative is 0 you have a
critical point where either the
derivative is 0 or the derivative is
undefined so this is a critical point
and let's explore what the derivative is
doing as we approach that point so in
order for this to be a maximum point the
function is increasing as we approach it
the function is increasing is another
way of saying that the slope is positive
the slope is changing but it stays
positive the whole time which means that
the function is increasing and the slope
being positive is another way of saying
that the derivative the derivative is
greater than 0 as we approach that point
now what happens as we pass that point
right at that point the slope is 0 but
then as we pass that point what has to
happen in order for that to be a maximum
point well the value of the function has
to go down the value of the function is
going down that means the slope is
negative and that's another way of
saying that the derivative the
derivative is the derivative is negative
so that seems like a pretty good
criteria for identifying whether a
critical point is a maximum point so
let's say that we have critical point
critical point a we are at a maximum
point we are at a max if if the if f
prime of X
if f prime of x switches signs switches
switches signs from positive to negative
from positive to negative as we cross as
we cross X as we cross x equals a that's
exactly what happened right over here
let's make sure it happened at our other
maximum point right over here so right
over here as we approach that point as
we approach that point the function is
increasing the function increasing means
that the slope is positive it's a
different positive slope the slope is
changing it's actually getting more and
more and more more steep which or more
and more and more positive but it is
definitely positive so it definitely
meets so it's positive going into that
point and then it becomes negative as
after we cross that point the slope was
undefined right at the point but it did
switch signs from positive to negative
as we crossed that critical point so
these both meet our criteria for being a
maximum point so so far our criteria
seems pretty good now let's make sure
that somehow this point right over here
which we identified in the last video as
a critical point let's make an I think
we call this to see this was X 0 this
was X 1 this was X 2 this was X 1 this
was X 2 so this is X 3 let's make sure
that this doesn't somehow meet the
criteria because we see visually that
this is not a maximum point so as we
approach this our slope is negative and
then as we cross it our slope is still
negative we're still decreasing so we
haven't switched signs so this does not
meet our criteria which is good now
let's come up with a criteria for a
let's come up with criteria for a
minimum point and I think you could see
where this is likely to go well we
identified in the last in the last video
that this right over here is a minimum
point we can see that it's a local
minimum just by looking at it and what's
the slope doing as we approach it so the
function is decreasing the slope is
negative as we approach it f prime of X
is less than zero as we approach that
point and then right after we cross it
this wouldn't be a minimum point if the
function if the
function where to keep decreasing
somehow the function needs to increase
now so let me do that same green so
right after that the function starts
increasing again f prime of X is greater
than zero so this seems like pretty good
criteria for minimum point f prime of x
switches switches signs signs from
negative to positive as we cross as we
cross a if we have critics some critical
point a we have a the function takes on
a minimum value at a if the derivative
of our function switches signs from
negative to positive as we cross a from
negative to positive now once again this
point right over here this critical
point X sub three does not meet that
criteria we go from negative and to zero
right at that point then stay go to
negative again so this is not a minimum
or a maximum point